[Applaudissements]
l'aventuré commence à ushuaïa c'est ici
que nous réceptionnons le matériel qui
est parti de france
huit jours avant nous la ville est
située au bord du canal naturel de
beagle qui sépare l'argentine au nord du
chili au sud
ce canal qui relie le pacifique à
l'atlantique traverse le sud de
l'amérique latine
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire ushuaïa n'a rien d'un village
c'est une ville de 45 mille habitants en
plein essor économique doté d'une vraie
structure hôtelière et même d'une
station de ski où choya attire les
touristes enivré par ce parfum de bout
du monde
treize mille kilomètres séparent paris
douche ou aia il faut compter 30 heures
de voyage pour atteindre 7 régions de
l'hémisphère sud
heureusement le décalage horaire est peu
important 4 heures en hiver et 5 heures
en été
[Musique]
des jet skis dans ce coin-là du monde
c'est une première légende ou choya
découvre l'existence de nos machines
los montes del agua comme il les appelle
avec un bon accent voilà notre camp de
base où sont réunis les 17 personnes qui
participe à l'expédition
rien n'est gagné d'avancé nous devons
encore faire le point avec les autorités
chiliennes pour obtenir l'autorisation
de doubler le cap horn est en fait
l'exploit c'est sa magnifique et les
machines pour cent vont râler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
première source de stress
la météo c'est l'élément déterminant de
notre aventure il n'y a plus qu'à
espérer que louis bodin notre routeur
météo basé à paris donne le feu vert
dernières nouvelles du temps vient de
recevoir les dernières cartes notamment
des services
des services argentin visiblement bastia
une fenêtre ça sera pour le 31 en fait
on avait prévu plutôt le samedi mais je
crois qu'avec les dernières cartes qu'on
vient de recevoir ce sera plutôt le 31
donc à mon avis il est techniquement
vous pouvez être prêt à ce moment là ça
devrait être le bon jour
j'attends j'attends de vos nouvelles la
confirmation de votre départ ça ils sont
sûrs la turbine
je pense oui
évidemment premiers jets d'oeufs cassés
c'est pour moi je prie pour qu'ils
dépensent au milieu du cap horn on peut
comprendre
[Musique]
m
parce que là c'est pas terrible
où
moi je suis monsieur plus de monsieur
sponsors organisateurs leur casquette
études et kohler de stickers ça fait de
travail on en met des plus gros sont pas
ces grosses sommes comme ils sont sympas
avec nous il faut leur faire de du
marquage et machina d'origine comprendre
90 95 km heure sur un lac bien calme
bien mais le plus importante c'est au
niveau sonorités et au niveau
consommation ces machines qui fait pas
du tout le bruit lundi si belle elle
consomme pas c'est l'injection
c'est plus importante déjà parce qu'on
n'embête personne dérange personne
c'est surtout sur ce niveau là c'est une
opération qui coûte un peu plus d'un
million et demi de francs donc c'est
quand même un gros budget et les jays
qui est pour moi encore un sport j'avais
confidentiel donc ça évolue beaucoup
mais il faut la foule le promouvoir donc
ce genre d'opération avec des vedettes
c'est quand même quelque chose de
formidable parce que ça permet de mettre
ça en avant
[Musique]
je suis le médecin de l'équipe
donc mon rôle sera d'assurer la sécurité
dont on médical des participants de
l'état
priorité bas des autres ceux qui vont
pas faire les sports
c'est les trois prochains jours essayer
de mettre en place une organisation de
relais et
téléphonique avec les hôpitaux à terre
au cas où il y aurait un vrai problème
normalement je suis un petit peu
entraîné pour ça g20 emploi j'ai 15 ans
de ça mais derrière moi donc ça devrait
pas trop mal se passer
poitiers
[Musique]
parce que le pousser au bout d'un moment
je tétanise
j'étais à nice énormément et du coup je
peux plus tenir le triage de via santé
quand on a fait le brave et vous éviter
de se faire mal faut éviter sur le kung
fu éviter de casser la machine et chaque
fois c'est que tout me regardait
réputation car ce coup l'immense
cordillère des andes fini sa course dans
cette région au bord du pacifique
nous sommes au début de l'automne et la
neige est déjà tombé le paysage sera
bientôt tout blanc et le thermomètre
descendra à une moyenne de -16 en hiver
[Musique]
c'est pas tous les matins qu'on se
réveille avec au soleil à l'autre côté
du rideau
[Musique]
non c'est pas d'enfant c'est un rêve
deux décennies depuis que je fais du jet
devrait bien aller dans un endroit
interdit inaccessible un truc ou alors
c'est un rêve qui devient réalité ouais
ouais mais le rêve est récent il n'y a
pas de tout petit j'ai mes rêves de
mômes et c'était pas spécialement ça
c'était ça rejoint en fait la globalité
tout c'est l'aventuré way ici c'est un
endroit qui respire laventure laventure
c'est un mot qui a été très galvaudé
pour moi c'est c'est sortir du troupeau
quoi c'est pas faire comme tout le monde
c'est sale aventure et c'est là où on
sent quand même vivant mais bon et c'est
la porte tout le monde non pas parce
qu'on a un boulot avec des horaires
fixes qu'on peut pas tenter l'aventuré
au contraire justement s'il suffit de
faire il suffit si on a la volonté de
vivre autrement et de se sentir plus
vivant que la moyenne des gens il faut
transgresser certaines choses établies
quoi c'est vrai que l'accident que j'ai
eue samedi à samedi a bien aidé merci
encore avant qu'alex et son accident il
m'a dit je vais traverser le cas formes
futuristes sûr que sur halak je suis là
tu as besoin de moi je suis là et puis
il ya deux ans en fait il ya quatre ans
ici votre en moto donc à l'hôpital
c'était son leitmotiv il disait tout le
temps mais je suis surtout à travers ce
qu'apporte sur mesure
il ya un an mais m'a téléphoné et m'a
dit on pas rocha por du bien sûr sur
alex et six mois et à pierre tourrenc
m'a applaudi la santé oms parc aventure
sur pied en juillet
parce que c'est qu'une équipe de
passionnés c'est une équipe d'avis tout
le monde se connaît tout le monde est là
pour la même chose tout le monde même
respect du travail de l'autre c'est
vraiment moi je suis invitée chez rien à
foot alors ça c'est pas de cambouis sur
les mains votre courbatures dans l'eau
juste le plaisir de piloter c'est un
grand cadeau qui me fait avec cela
[Musique]
oui
alors évidemment la température de l'eau
elle n'est pas très estival saint tropez
c'est assez loin ici il ya quelques
jours il faisait moins 4 ou pas de toute
façon je peux descendre à moins 10 du
jour au lendemain et la flotte devait
être à 4 degrés quoique on va descendre
encore plus au sud donc pour le horn je
pense qu'on va se retrouver dans une eau
entre 4 et 6 degrés quoi quand on
traverse apparemment ce que nous a dit
louis bodin il ya il ya 4-5 mètres
résiduelles sur 300 mètres de long donc
ça va passer parce que finalement le
problème du cap ça va pas être tellement
les jet skis monsieur ce qui tient lieu
dans une tempête c'est le bouchon de
liège et à choisir entre le jet et du
bateau beaucoup plus confiant le jet que
le bateau il faut aussi qu'on vérifie
l'installation céline deville alors je
peux je préconise à l'arrière de
promettre un mousqueton tout simplement
la repasser devant que ça fait un nom
comme ça et par contre après faut
installer toute la ligne de vie sous la
sanction l'arrière à la cent à la sangle
de la seule il faut tout posé la scène
de la salle et votre est-ce qu'on a les
armes et parce qu'il ya que les
combinaisons rouges qui ont des anneaux
tu sais tu reviens moi sur ma jun j'ai
pas de harnais et toi tu en auras pas
non plus mais je vais essayer c'est la
boissière
si ça marche donc eu presque à chaque
borne et je suis pas monsieur sécurité
je suis monsieur bateau et aurait
peut-être été plus important peut-être
que les jets parce que les jets sont
tributaires des bateaux systématiquement
aussi bien pour les ravitaillements que
pour tout ce qui peut se passer en cas
de pépin
sécurité va avec bateau mais bateau et
bateau très important puisqu'il faut une
autonomie il faut des bateaux capables
de passer une mer formée si elle se
forme rapidement
donc on va pas partir avec n'importe
quoi et c'est pour ça qu'on affine déjà
depuis deux jours le problème qui va se
régler aujourd'hui clair et net
vous verrez des bateaux ni cas elle
pourrait affronter le cap horn également
tout le monde en forme
la sangle en lorraine parce qu'on sait
pas trop dire comment ça se passe à ce
truc là semblent de l'eau de quoi me
fais parce que c'est important il faut
manger pendant huit heures c'est non et
puis quoi d'autre 300 des jerrycans pour
300 litres d'essence donc on va y
arriver
[Musique]
en faisant qu'ils quittent estimations
un peu trop rapide je pense qu'il est
pire s'est trompé une centaine d'équipés
y mêle donc il a estimé environ 200
kilomètres à parcourir
il y en a à peu près 320 donc c'est pour
ça que c'est important de de toujours
vérifier comme ça et de faire un calcul
très précis c'est une grande expérience
parce que je pense que c'est un salut au
mythique et ensuite les jet skis fait
également une grande expérience et pour
eux et puis pour l'ensemble du milieu
motonautique parce que le jet ski est
tellement considéré comme un sport à
part tout ce qui est marin ou nautiques
je pense ça sera ça sera une grande
première de le faire en jet mais c'est
pas une petite histoire c'est pas une
petite opération c'est un c'est une
grande aventure c'est pas tout droit il
faut passer entre des îles donc il faut
prévoir tous les passages essayer de
d'anticiper un petit peu les difficultés
que l'on va rencontrer et puis surtout
regarder un petit peu la distance à
parcourir pour aller giffords et en
revenir y en a en tant que maître nageur
et puis sauter à l'eau s'il faut chaud
talent au quotidien problème si tu voi e
pour le jet soit être n'importe quoi
pour me voulez quoi
il faut pas sur cette question était là
pour se régaler on est quand même équipe
et on part pas en string et on a commis
dans de survie et ça ça ça fait du bien
contre ça réchauffe
très vite c'est autre chose
oria du tricot stérile dames 1 sans le
citer
mais il faut quand même le dire et
combinaisons en polaire qui donne un peu
loupé babygro mais part de la flotte à 4
degrés on s'en fout de s'appeler baby
gros ensuite on a une combinaison 100%
étanche
alors ensuite la démarche it et se fait
par un petit tas autre chose on va tirer
avec les jets avaient une paire de
chaussettes néoprène et déjà posée
comme ça là on est étanche et on a chaud
[Applaudissements]
parce que je danger l'ennemi du du froid
c'est le show il suffit qu'on n'ait pas
froid ou moins qu'on est trop chaud on
se met à transpirer et quand on est
mouillé à l'intérieur ces flux et c'est
là qu'on a vraiment froid parce qu'on a
fait à réchauffer sa sa propre
transpiration et par dessus tout ça une
paire de pompes antidérapante et bien
des touches et là on peut taper de l'eau
à 3 degrés sans problème passer le cap
horn aujourd'hui c'est relativement
facile le passé dans du chat si on ne
sait pas si c'est faisable donc on
essaye et c'est ça qui est qui me plaît
le plus c'est de partir et faire des
trucs que les autres n'ont jamais fait
non ce qui motive c'est uniquement faire
des trucs pas facile si ce faire ce qui
a déjà été fait je viens me font pas
grand grand grand intérêt
moi ce qui me motive le plus c'est
vraiment faire des trucs ont fait qu'une
fois dans sa vie et que beaucoup de gens
aimeraient faire et qui ne font pas le
faire avec avec avec alex et une
sécurité parce que ça avec qui pilote
très bien lui que ça sera pas un gros
problème parce que même s'il n'a pas une
grande expérience du jet
c'est un gros sportif qui sait ce que
c'est que les grosses sensations donc
c'est pas un panique heures puis c'est
un mec qui sait écouter si tu lui dis un
moment ça devient vraiment dangereux
tu arrêtes tout et tu me suis je suis ma
trace aussi bien que si un jour je fais
du ski avec lui et qui me dit il ya
danger tu me laisses des skis je
l'écouterai je pense que sur ce coup là
il est assez intelligente
alors je vais vous donner un scoop on
secoue pas là
si je dois avoir une dernière pensée
elle sera là
enfin monter un petit mot que ma femme
aille très utile quand on fait des trucs
comme ça il ya vraiment une émotion qui
serait et moi qui suis assez facilement
me
je sais que je passerais pas le cas pas
de sens sans pleurer le casque les
lunettes
une paire de feu d'igor s'il fait pas
froid c'est pas la peine d'avoir des
gros gants parce qu'il faut avoir un bon
grip sur les poignets puis s'ils
commencent à faire réellement froid là
on sort le néoprène 3 mm avec du grip à
l'intérieur pour bien accroché l'oeil le
caoutchouc le nez de cochon
s'il fait très très très froid sous le
masque comme ça sous casque et puis la
ligne de vie ça c'est d'un des trucs qui
vous sauve la vie si vous êtes éjecté du
jet parce que le problème quand on tombe
des jet skis par grand vent c'est qu'on
a beaucoup de mal à rattraper le jet ski
donc ça ça vous permet de ce fait comme
ça à bras dans chaque fois qu'on claque
on est toujours en contact avec le
budget il est un peu chaud pépère il va
y aller
[Musique]
comme souvent dans nos vallées nord
tom vaughan dans l'embardée nos mac os
google
[Musique]
son nom
bon
[Musique]
ton envers nous
à tort ou google dans l'embardée nous
que nous
[Musique]
comme ça
il est prévu que luc alphand nous
rejoigne plus tarder
en attendant on vérifie notre matériel
soumis à des conditions inhabituelles
d'eau très froides et les moteurs de jet
ski sanem pas franchement l'eau glacée
ils peuvent casser à tout moment et il
faut à tout prix éviter la moindre panne
mécanique c'est synonyme d'abandon
parce qu'évidemment on ne trouve pas de
pièces de rechange au bout du monde
[Musique]
je
pour l'instant nous avons de la chance
pas un nuage à l'horizon est ici c'est
rare alors sous la haute surveillance de
la cordillère des andes
nous profitons de la beauté de l'endroit
et surtout du plat de l'eau
récréation on ne pense à rien on s'amuse
un peu comme le calme avant la tempête
une chose est sûre ça ne va pas être
tout le temps comme ça
[Musique]
devant rosberg
j'allais bien
elle était dans l'avion quand tu vas
bientôt
ça me ferait pour
les parties
quand on voit là en arrivant là c'est
pas moi ça me fait penser vraiment à ce
que j'aime un peu de suède un peu d'un
peu de norvège un peu de neige un peu de
montagne ça déjà ça me plaît et là je
suis content après on verra si les
conditions sont bonnes puisqu'au bon on
n'est pas là pour faire les barjots je
sais qu'on du sens aux matières et
partir avec vincent et alec c'est ça qui
est dangereux c'est partir avec vincent
et alex vincent premiers veulent c'est
eux les fous bon ben on y va
l'udc est arrivé il ne manquait plus que
lui pour que l'équipe se retrouve au
complet on va pouvoir y aller pour de
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au poteau
france ces lois ou tabitha
[Applaudissements]
gagner et c'est que l'hélice a failli
repartir à la bataille et nous les ai
livré par la wta mais on a pris des
algues on a prêté des lits sur le bateau
d'accompagnement donc il fallait
absolument une hélice et puis au dernier
moment avait pas arrivé à trouver par
ici à ushuaia donc selon lui de buenos
aires à 0 pris l'avion avec luc et
philippe wahl hockey et des parcs en bas
dans une heure départ dans une heure
acura seul fait plaisir parce que lui
qu'il est avec les skieurs les vrais
skieurs l'avait qui ont monté une
station de ski s'appelle cerro castor là
et fera station de ski à ushuaia dirais
qu'à son regard gaston a pas parce que
tu sais qu'il y en a pas beaucoup et les
descendeurs a échoué cet apport pour
[Musique]
on contemple et 3 soit la culture est
très content parce que c'est quand même
définitivement l'aboutissement de
l'opération
donc ça va pouvoir commencer devrait
vous l'avez très content que lui soit
arrivé
et puis après il faut réussir
l'opération donc c'est ce qu'on devrait
pouvoir faire
embarquement immédiat de tout le
matériel 1300 litres d'essence 800 kg de
fret de bateaux pneumatiques et nous
reste 2 3 formalités administratives à
régler pour quitter définitivement le
territoire argentin
on a on a les douanes qui s'entend nous
faire gagner deux heures de temps et
comme ils sont très ils sont très
sensibles aux petits gestes à une photo
une dédicace comme ils connaissent luc
alphand qui lui est une star mondiale ça
leur fait plaisir d'avoir l'équipe
ça s'appelle les pots-de-vin mais à ce
niveau là je veux bien joué moi
d'un administratif la repos l ont fait
les papiers des sorties des droits pour
les bâtons pour les motos
l'inde est avec un chef immigration pour
enfermer les sorties des peines et ont
réparti un petit peu dans chaque bateau
en fonction des autorisations sont là
pour faciliter un petit peu les nôtres
entreprises et shelly parce que sinon on
va rester entre les eaux argentines et
les eaux chiliennes ont bien trop cool
je n'ai plus de faire des ronds de
jambes et de serre et les louchart et
bientôt à marier brushing ses poumons et
qui leur suspect à bahia toujours des
réglages de dernière minute mais ça
colle tous partis dans le bateau dans un
petit moment on est parti après c'est
obligé nous confions away
confiant il a juste le créneau météo et
c'est demain avec le décalage horaire on
est des solides
on fait tout je fais aussi une star de
la télévision je fais tout cheveux
finalement je vais chevaux capable en
voiture arrivant pick up
je suis dégoûté de la vie chez toi aussi
tu as des couilles
c'était vraiment qu'on sait c'est que tu
es vraiment qu'on sait ce qui va te
cacher derrière toi je me caille jamais
pas lui l'époque que de la gueule il l'a
fait il y en a 15 mois qu'il est déjà
posé la question
alors voilà je veux passer le cap horn à
la nage j retour mais avant de prendre
le départ on reçoit la visite surprise
d'une équipe de télévision argentine
intéressés et surtout intrigué par notre
expédition
on peut les comprendre
[Musique]
on entre maintenant dans le vif du sujet
en laissant derrière nous le confort de
la ville d'où choya pour une route
rempli d'incertitudes
cap sur le chili vers puerto williams où
on se préparera véritablement à
atteindre notre but devenir les premiers
cap hornier en jet ski
alors on n'a plus le choix on fonce
et un dernier salut aux militaires
argentins qui visiblement sont à quai
pour nous
[Musique]
l'udc à des heures de sommeil a récupéré
tout le monde le sait la croisière
s'amuse
même les plus grands sportifs pour
passer douche ouailles à puerto williams
nous traversons le détroit de beagle
d'ouest en est sur 30 nautiques pour
planter notre camp de base
klein
premier problème panne sèche
après seulement 40 minutes de navigation
sans titre le bateau consomme plus que
prévu
[Musique]
les bagages vous m
mon pauvre
puerto williams mills 600 âmes dont 800
militaires et un seul et unique hôtel où
le touriste se fait rare pour ne pas
dire complètement absente
c'est à croire qu'il a été construit
uniquement pour nous la beauté du
paysage est à couper le souffle
rien à ajouter juste se taire et
regarder
ben écoute moi je prends une grande
claque dans la gueule et là tu dis
sérénité humilité et quand on est arrivé
bon évidemment il y avait à peine plus
route touristes travelprice cas quand on
est arrivés à la pause et les jets ainsi
nord jusqu'à ce que bobo la chine caisse
évidemment mais c'est m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernière soirée avant le grand départ
pour le cap horn
pendant qu'une partie de l'équipe des
charges le matériel georges et didier
négocié serré avec les autorités
chiliennes pour notre départ fixé le
lendemain matin par louis bodin prêté un
bateau pour qu'on puisse mettre notre
essence abordent à 30 à l'heure même si
notre façon plombé on l'abandonné la
dernière plage de ravitaillement et nous
on termine avec avec l'autre l'autre
rapide là qui va beaucoup plus vite
qu'ils consomment mois avec les
jerrycans à bord ont fait le tour on
double horn et puis on revient et à
l'hôtel nous avons tous rendez vous avec
le douanier chilien
et j'ai touché la théorie du chili
beaucoup s'étaient samoa 17-10
il est sain il
kapo zapper et à palpiter l'isi
ça y est tout est réglé apparemment on a
des ravitaillements qui ont été faits
par l'armée chilienne
tout est nickel parfaitement serein pour
besoin pour l'instant la seule gestion
que j'ai eu à faire de problèmes de
santé étaient des ampoules aux pieds la
turista et le mal de gorge et vu les
conditions météo et les conditions de
surveillance
et l'assistance demain je pense que ça
va se passer et les combes et viable le
mâle décalage il commence à peser
bientôt je vais faire la cuisine qui
cherchent à bouffer avant de m'endormir
demain bien un docteur un maître nageur
et un pilote sur le bateau de sécurité
pour encadrer lytro foule
ça devrait bien se passer n'y a pas de
problème tu m'excuses me lâche sécher
mes affaires ont à peu près le temps
c'est que ça soit sec de morts il y en
ait trois pilotes donc la place est
chère on a un stand obligatoire avec la
modeste de l'armée ici d'accord pour
dire que vos sens et obligatoire
tu as la chance sourit aux audacieux
nous avons obtenu l'autorisation d'aller
jusqu'au cap horn vit à lille lennox
avec en prime le soutien logistique des
chiliens qui soit dit en passant nous
prennent toujours pour des fous non
seulement les autorisations en plus on a
le soutien de l'armée
donc comme si relativement rares
que l'armée soutiennent autant un groupe
de lui même localement un des tauliers
en chef qui vient voir d'abord à quoi
ressemble un jet ski qui n'ont jamais vu
de gestion et quand ils ont vu le g10
viennent nous voir ne jamais vous êtes
sûr vous allez passer le cap horn au
conte à makeen c'est vrai que depuis
quelques jours chaque fois qu'on voit
des locaux ont leurs défauts des locaux
à ce que ça veut dire fou justement il
est question ce à chaque fois qu'on voit
des gens du coin mais qu'est ce que vous
faites
il ya va passer le cap avec le jet ski
et tout le monde nous fait franz 40 km
de l'argentine on a perdu une heure mais
donc ce qui est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle puisqu'on va dormir une heure
de plus ça c'est le bon plan mais nos
camarades qui sont partis dormir juste
avant eux croient toujours que il
travaille ses cinq heures mais lui
quatre ans il est déjà couché de pudeur
les personnes veut aller réveiller pour
lui dire finalement on dort une heure
c'est quoi la prochaine journée
barre toi tu sais que tu rentres sans
frapper si je suis à poil comment tu
fais la nuit a été courte
nous ne sommes pas frais comme des
gardons mais on est quand même prêt à se
jeter à l'eau même froide
[Musique]
c'est quoi qu on est excité c'est que
l'impression qu'on porte pour la planète
mars où on va marcher sur la lune un peu
pareil voilà c'est qu'à part de merde
[Musique]
oui ma loge
oui ma loge regarder les conditions
idéales et on se baigner fait boule de
neige
la mer c'est génial en cas d'urgence
ça regarde bien pu dire cimpor ouais
ouais ouais mais on n'a rien à dékon pas
on déconne pour un jeu placé les élus
dire ça fort et tu baises toi le grand
dax
mais tout boulot il est un autre fait ce
qu'on bossait à ceux qui ont tout
préparé ce qu'est née la le cours du
boulot chaîne logistique ici qui est le
plus dur à mettre en place
on a plus loin de tout et c'est un peu
de plaisir aujourd'hui regardez ce beau
sa vieille halle seul truc qui fait
c'est qu'on les oblige elles attendent
les bateaux à chien n'est pas toi qu'on
payait fait ce qu'il fallait pour à elle
sur la lame ombres et des champions
[Applaudissements]
on à toute précision tous les gaffes ou
la bombe
regardez c'est pas bon cerveau car les
nombreux on est à l'envers
attendez on revient au plat ok on a tout
les cas qu'on ne voudrait rentrer le
sorgho ce menton avec les bateaux de
l'armée
nous sommes et si on descend la détente
et il est neuf
on vient c'est un concept est ici on se
rencontre avec le bateau de l'armée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jorg way combien de temps de préparation
quatre ans bref les quatre mois de
préparation à cinq personnes a coulé la
helaba là un peu malheureux de paille
sur le cheap quand même malheureux mais
c'est une superbe finition piste
petite fumée dans le royaume se révèle
avoir ça le fait bien
et oui ça le fait d'autant plus que
fidèle à sa réputation louis bodin ne
s'est pas trompé il fait incroyablement
beau
ok on a une vitesse de 4 points 9 km
heure évincé en fait c'est un
gps qu'on appelle c'est un global
positionning system voilà globale
positive
ça nous permet de savoir à n'importe
quel moment où on se trouve et où on a
repéré des poids hier soir pour faire la
route on a repéré des points précis sur
la carte et on a un système qui nous
permet de diriger jusqu'à ce point
c'est petit appareil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
oh
[Musique]
contrairement aux idées reçues le jet
ski ne peut lui presque pas quatre fois
moins en tout cas qu'un hors-bord
il s'intègre la nature et s'adapte au
genre de la randonnée le jet ski est par
ailleurs sans danger car ils ne
possèdent pas d'hélices extérieur mais
une turbine qui propulse un jet d'eau la
preuve nos amis les phoques qui
d'habitude fuyez bateau de peur de se
faire prendre par les hélices viennent
se faire masser par notre jet comme dans
un jacuzzi
la traversée continue entre les îles
navarino et lennox et se poursuivra dans
la baie de nassau en direction de
l'archipel des wallace tonnes dont fait
partie l'île horn qui est la plus au sud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
impossible de ravitailler bord à bord à
cause de la houle nous devons chargé
laissant sur les pneumatiques pour comme
prévu accosté sur l'île les noces
[Musique]
normalement il ya des immeubles qu'on
prend dans la gueule
et la france a prédit
à part qu' un parti à la can break
il ya un peu de neige
[Musique]
ce héros grâce à l'art
ce bout de terre immergé presque
inhabitées et soit un tremplin pour le
cap soit l'ultime étape de notre
aventure
tout dépend des chiliens on aligne des
nox
mais on n'a pas choisi le bon endroit
pour beach et tu vois c'est des cailloux
alors que juste en face aux pieds la
petite falaise à ces magnifiques pour
plus c'était du sable mais bon
[Applaudissements]
parfois les volets répétons ici c'est
bien sûr regardé le mec qui prône les
sens il en a qui va pas bien ok on était
un petit peu la juge donne de
l'information
on doit rester là jusqu'à ce qu'il nous
rappelle on a priori le l'hélicoptère
est sorti il arrive à fort william
mais d'ici moins d'une heure on devrait
avoir la confirmation qu'on a le droit
de configurer mais bon il faut
s'attendre à rester 20 minutes ici à peu
près
20 minutes qui vont finalement se
transformer en deux heures et à nouveau
celle angoisse car plus le temps passe
plus la possibilité de doubler le cap
horn dans la journée s'éloigner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est les angoisses de quatre mois de
boulot pas dit non parce qu'on était peu
pour gérer cette affaire
sire que d'ailleurs ça se voit
aujourd'hui beaucoup de choses qui
soient un petit peu en termes
d'improvisation que c'était quatre mois
difficiles de mise en route à 4 ou 5
personnes s'étaient pas pas toujours
simple
enfin nous on est là non je suis comme
ma femme aurait vraiment voulu être là
c'est qu'elle avait tout à fait le
niveau en jet ski pour le faire j'essaie
de faire partager un petit peu le ferry
et les jets à l'eau sur un autre ton que
je suis tu vois pas changer henry cabine
téléphonique d'où le temps qu'on a passé
à petit on est mal barré
j'aurais si quelque chose comme 250 km
est vieux qu'on met du temps à avancer
la fois bien bel objet l'attend
l'autorisation de chignin là pour
continuer donc
donc voila quoi on fait avec mais ça sur
verdon 140 35 boutiques et dans ce
moment là que la magnifique
les seize fois la van singer
ok on les adore hausse on va sur os
maintenant ok on a libre l'autorisation
d'y aller l'hélico est en route
oui
pour les porter
[Musique]
et
à bord
[Musique]
vague de 1,22 mètre d'eau
on est parlante
vent du nord secteur nord il est prévu
plus tôt nord-est
venir que la dépression est arrivé
il est très vite que prévu
[Musique]
devant de si j'arrive 6 2 pour avoir
plus de mary sidioca portes de paris
bravo c'est là tu retournes campagne
d'aller bien
c'est ça la colle de matri si je ne
démentais carpeaux tu vas le branché du
trou j'attends corps dans l'eau le
problème c'est qu'un
[Applaudissements]
il s'arrête et vous mes canons allez on
y va
c'est mon bébé
les problèmes électriques et une demande
de contact
une pièce gameplay qui déçoivent
sadriste arrive très rarement mais ça
arrive
nous sommes en contact
charice deviennent rapidement
[Musique]
on n'est pas plus ce matin toujours à
peu près mais il a été meilleur
là on commence à tenter en compilant est
hélas et ses moeurs
je veux dire c'est mr place dont la
borne alors là là où l'on la moine
damien mais je n'allais pas y avoir cinq
ou six mètres legrand de moules et fait
un petit relief c'est des fois on voit
plus alex ans qui en seulement cinq ans
mais à côté
et défend les voit plus mais ça a l'air
d'être cool
plus on descend vers le sud plus la mer
se creuse mais les conditions
météorologiques restent quand même
exceptionnel et il faut le savoir
cela n'arrive en moyenne que quatre
jours par an
[Musique]
chicago
commence à être vraiment une belle
balade jeu
et hop je
voilà
une façon melanchon
c'est pas bien bonne
[Musique]
avec les jets c'est bon
oh
le mans
après huit heures de navigation depuis
notre départ de puerto williams ne
touchons enfin au but
le cap horn
les chiliens ont été les derniers à
franchir ce passage à la voile sur des
navires de commerce avant l'ouverture du
canal de panama
c'est un endroit mythique pour tous les
marins du monde qui en passant là
peuvent apercevoir cet albatros de métal
érigé par les chiliens en hommage à tous
ceux qui ont laissé la vie
[Musique]
vu de l'hélicoptère le passage ne paraît
pas impressionnant ni même dangereux
pourtant sur un saut de vagues
luc alphand est éjecté à 15 mètres de
son jet mais de toute façon il avait
connu pire sur la neige
toutes les conditions sont réunies pour
ne pas mettre inutilement nos vies en
danger
et c'est bien ce que nous voulions nous
ne sommes pas là pour jouer les
kamikazes
mais pour approcher un mythe
[Musique]
la houle est longue mais le creux des
vagues atteint tout de même eu m les
bateaux d'assistance ne peuvent pas
passer trop dangereux pour eux alors
nous doublerons le horn seul avec un
plein d'essence et rien d'autre et ce
jour là le cap horn nous a laissé passer
à
[Musique]
la nuit sur le point de tomber et nous
sommes très en retard sur notre timing
le retour en jet ski s'avère impossible
alors c'est le bateau deux militaires
chiliens qui nous ramène à puerto
williams dans la cabine
on a juste envie de laisser éclater
notre joie et notre fierté d'avoir
réussi contre vents et marées je suis un
vrai gentil la marseillaise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça faisait longtemps qu'on n'avait pas
chanté mais finalement on s'est tous
sont venus des paroles est comme ça
faisait très plaisir à nos amis chiliens
on leur devait bien ça
[Musique]
laura et quand c'est si long combat
aux citoyens
les bataillons marchons marchons à voir
océans ou jean boucheron là que mon
journal dans novarino
tom vaughan d'emballer nomades bouchons
[Musique]
autour d'un verre des nomades or google
dans le baden powell que bulls